اتفاق نقل الحبوب على طاوله مجلس الامن
تحولت الجلسه التي خصصها المحفل الدولي
لمناقشه تداعيات الانسحاب الروسي من
الاتفاق الى ساحه للتحذير والقاء
الاتهامات وطرح مبادرات ايضا موقف الامم
المتحده بقي على حاله بسعيها لاعاده تفعيل
الاتفاق لكن وكيله الامين العام للشؤون
السياسيه حذرت من احتمال حدوث مواجهه
عسكريه ناجمه عن حادث عسكري في البحر
الاسود
نحث بشده على ضبط النفس تجاه اي خطاب او
عمل اخر من شانه ان يؤدي الى تدهور الوضع
الخطير بالفعل اما وكيل الامين العام
للشؤون الانسانيه فاشار الى ارتفاع اسعار
الحبوب وعوده شبح الجوع الى ملايين الناس
خلاصه القول ان صادره الاغذيه والاسمده من
اوكرانيا وروسيا لا تزال تكتسي اهميه قصوى
لضمان الامن الغذائي العالمي
وكذلك ان لم يتغير الموقف الروسي المستعد
لاستئناف الاتفاق بعد رفع العقوبات على
المنتجات الزراعيه الروسيه رغم تقييمه
بتحول طبيعه الاتفاق من انسانيه الى
تجاريه لكون دوجن
لا ينبغي لاحد ان يفاجئ بالقرار الذي
اتخذناه بتعليق مبادره البحر الاسود
وانتهاء الممر الانساني البحري الان جميع
السفن المتوجهه الى مياه البحر الاسود
والموانئ الاوكرانيه ستعتبر من قبلنا
ناقلات لشحنات عسكريه على الطرف المقابل
اتهم المندوب الاوكراني روسيا بالسعي
لترهيب الدول وخلو اعلانها من اي هدف
عسكري مشروع او استثناءات طبيه وانسانيه
وفق قوانين الحرب البحريه دعا المسؤول
الاوكراني من منبر مجلس الامن العالم الى
اتخاذ اجراءات تضمن سلامه الملاحه في
البحر الاسود كضمان للامن الغذائي في كل
العالم
لا يمكن تبرير عمل روسيا باي من قواعد
القانون الدولي بما في ذلك حق المتحاربين
في الحصار اما الولايات المتحده عبر
مندوبتها اشارت الى ان روسيا تصدر حبوبها
اكثر من اي وقت وبسعر اعلى وان الوقت لم
ينفد بعد كي تتراجع موسكو عن موقفها
الحالي وتعيد تفعيل
الاتفاقيه لوحدها شنت روسيا جوله جديده من
الهجمات على اودستا روسيا تشن حربا على
امدادات الغذاء في العالم
كما لم يغب تحضير اطراف حاضره للاجتماع من
تحول البحر الاسود الى منطقه خطيره لا
يؤمن فيها ابحار السفن المدنيه